Nothing in life can prepare you for the raw heat
of a house on fire. Throwing an arm up in front of
his eyes and clasping a handkerchief to his mouth,
Robert Chetford hacked up half of the contents of
his lungs. Glancing at the material, he saw that
his phlegm was black, poisoned by the smoke.
A beam collapsed in front of him, sending
a fresh wave of burning air into his face,
so hot that it felt like it was going
to scorch his ears off. He had to run,
he had to get out of the house, but he
knew he couldn't. His mother was upstairs.
Robert barreled his way through the flames,
shouldering open doors and stumbling along
hallways. The air was so thick with
smoke that he could hardly breathe,
so he collapsed to the floor and started
to crawl on his stomach. He reached the
first step of the grand staircase and
started to heave himself up one at a time,
feeling the heat of the house threatening to
engulf him more with every inch he climbed.
But he hadn't made it more than five steps
before there was an enormous creaking sound,
and the whole staircase collapsed beneath
him. Sparks rushed up into the air and
swirled around the room. Flames licked at the
walls all around him. As Robert looked around
at the collapsed staircase, he knew that it was
hopeless. With tears streaming down his cheeks,
he pushed himself forward
and ran out of the house.
The firemen swarmed past him, filling
the building and shouting to one another,
but Robert just stood there, staring up at
the top-floor window. On the other side of
the glass, surrounded by billowing
smoke, he looked up at his mother,
sitting as she always did on her rocking chair,
utterly motionless as the house burned around her…
In an undisclosed facility in
the United States of America,
you will find what may well be the
lowest-security containment cell
in the entire SCP Foundation. There is no
heavily armored door, no bulletproof glass,
no machine guns about to drop down from the
ceiling at any point. In fact, there's very
little in the way of containment at all, they
often leave the door to the cell wide open.
There is a window, but on the other side of it
isn't a crowd of researchers, security guards,
and agents ready to spring into
action at a moment's notice. It's
just a normal double-glazed window that looks
out across a vista of fields, trees, and a
couple of power lines. Facing the window is an old
armchair in which the Concrete Man sits. SCP-014.
He spends all of his day, every day,
staring out of the window. This view
specifically was chosen because very
little changes in it. Night turns to day,
the trees change with the seasons, and it
rains occasionally, but there are no roads,
no new buildings springing up, nothing to
distinguish it from how it looked in 1937.
Beside him is a small table, home to a
record player. In the corner of the room,
there's an antique set of shelves that house
three dozen records, all dated from the 1930s
or earlier. All day, every day, the music
plays out of the old speaker. Every so often,
as researchers walk up and down the corridor,
if they hear that there isn't any music playing,
they'll come into the room and change the record
over for a new one. The newer researchers check
in with SCP-014 to see if he's okay. He rarely
responds, and so before long, they stop asking.
You would think, therefore, that the
concrete man is elderly, approaching
the twilight years of his life. But the man
who sits there in his chair, staring out of
the window and listening to music from almost
100 years ago, appears to be just 30 years old.
*
Friends of Robert Chetford reported
a noticeable change in his demeanor
following the fire and the death of his
mother. He had lost his father not long
before to a workplace accident. William
Chetford had been a construction worker,
climbing up the girders of New York's emerging
skyline, pouring concrete and piling bricks.
He had been working on a new building, one
that was set to be the tallest in the world,
called the Empire State Building. Day
after day, he would climb the cranes,
teeter precariously over the
dizzying drops. Any slight
mistake and he would plummet hundreds of
feet, often to the busy streets below.
Sure enough, one day, William Chetford's
worst fears came to life. He was walking
on a gangplank that wobbled and bent with every
step he took. On his shoulders was a metal bar
with a bucket of concrete dangling precariously
from each tip. He walked this route every day,
but clearly, that day proved
too much for the wood to take.
The board splintered and split beneath
him, plunging him down and down through
the scaffolding. William desperately reached
out an arm and managed to grasp the edge of
a girder. He hung there helplessly, staring up
at his colleagues high above him. He cried out
for help, and upon seeing him, they began
to scramble down level by level to try and
reach him. He just needed to hang on for a
moment longer, and they would rescue him.
But one of them knocked over a bucket of concrete.
William Chetford could do nothing but watch as
the heavy sludge slowly tumbled towards his
face. He tried to dodge it, but it was no use.
The company told Mrs. Chetford that
this had been William's saving grace,
that he had been unconscious for the
long fall down to the streets below. His
fellow workers knew that wasn't the case.
They heard his screams all the way down.
Mrs. Chetford didn't believe any of it. They were
lying, all of them—the company, his co-workers,
everybody. She knew what had really killed him.
It was the same thing that was killing her slowly,
the same thing that had been passed
onto their son: concrete poisoning.
She'd approached the Wall Street Journal, New York
Times, and any outlets she could, but none of them
were remotely interested in the story. There were
chemicals in the concrete; it wasn't safe to use,
it never had been. She'd worked in nursing homes
and seen the effects of concrete on construction
workers. They'd become paralyzed, unable to move,
spending so many years breathing concrete air,
letting it absorb into their skin. Their bodies
had slowly started to turn into it. She knew it.
She started to go crazy, pinning up news
clippings, medical journals, photographs,
maps—anything she could find—all over her
walls, her entire bedroom. She had red string
hanging from the walls and ceiling, connecting
to every surface. Robert watched helplessly from
the doorway, unable to do anything as he saw
his mother steadily entering into psychosis.
But the further her paranoia went, the less
energy she seemed to have for it. Weeks went by,
and her manic fervor was replaced with lethargy.
She got slower and slower in her movements,
talked less and less at meal times, and began
to sit down for extended chunks of the day.
Robert, assuming that she was tired from
grief, did what he could to help. He carried
an armchair up to her room and placed it
in the corner by the window so that she
could look out over the world around her. He
thought she was resting. But it soon became
apparent that she wasn't really resting;
she was withdrawing, almost freezing over.
Desperate to try and get his mother to re-engage
with the world, Robert sat down with her to try
and understand all of her conspiracy theories
around his father's death. She explained slowly
and calmly that the concrete being used in New
York was poisoned, cursed. She didn't know where
it had been dug up from, how it had been mixed,
or who was behind it, but she was getting close.
Maybe it was the US government, maybe it was
the same witches, maybe it was God himself.
But she knew her husband, and she
knew he wouldn't have fallen that
day. He had walked across that plank
thousands of times without incident;
there was no way he would have made that mistake.
Robert tried to connect the dots of what she was
saying. Did she really think that it was
the concrete that had killed his father?
She said that it was and that the
same concrete is now killing her.
She showed him her hands, turned them over, front
and back, under the light for him to inspect.
They looked just like normal hands—elderly,
wrinkled, with deep veins popping out—but normal.
She scratched at them and tried to feign
pain for the effects of her fingers.
"Look," she said, "you see that powder
coming off them? That's concrete powder."
But Robert didn't see any of it.
*
The concrete man came to the Foundation's
attention a couple of decades ago. Construction
workers in New York in the late 1990s were
hard at work clearing out the foundations
for a new skyscraper. The site was built on
top of what used to be a residential block,
but one intrepid builder soon discovered
something that shook him to his core.
There was an old cellar beneath where the building
used to be. The lock on it was heavy, thick with
rust, and hadn't been opened for close to 70
years. He and his team managed to pry it open,
put on their flashlights, and went inside. What
they found was a basement apartment still sitting
there beneath the rubble. It was a relic of
its time. Thick dust covered every surface,
ugly wallpaper surrounded them, and ancient
appliances covered with rust sat in the kitchen.
It was almost like walking
through a haunted house.
The builders joked about ghosts stalking these
corridors as they made their way through,
until they reached the bedroom. Sliding the
door open, they faced a man sitting there,
staring at them from an old armchair. The four
burly builders screamed like little girls for
a split second, then burst out laughing when they
realized the man wasn't real. He must have been a
waxwork or something. He was sitting so perfectly
still and hadn't reacted at all to their presence.
They went over to inspect what he was made
out of. They tapped on his forehead, lifted
his arms and dropped them, and were surprised
at how convincing the fake man was. That was,
of course, until he politely asked them
not to touch him. This time they really
did scream like girls, running straight out
of that basement into a local police station.
*
This basement apartment was where Robert
Chetford moved following the fire in his
parents' home and the death of his paralyzed
mother. Racked with guilt, he had never
quite been able to process what had happened to
cause his mother's mental state to deteriorate
so rapidly. By the time she died, she had
been looking at her hands and genuinely
believing they were made of concrete.
She would not move, she would not eat,
she would not sleep. For days, she would
just sit, staring out of her window.
He knew he should have taken her to a doctor, but
they just couldn't afford it. Maybe if he had,
this would have all worked out differently.
Robert would think about it hour after hour.
He would sit down in the armchair in the corner
of his room and ponder what had happened. It was
difficult to keep track of time living
in the basement—there were no windows,
no daylight at all—but he didn't
think he had been sitting there for
very long when he noticed the skin
on his hands starting to turn gray.
Without panic, he slowly lifted his hands to
his eyes and inspected what was happening. His
fingers, down to about halfway through his palms,
were dry and solid. He could move them just about,
but it took a normal effort, and he could see
cracks running along the back of the concrete
when he did. So he decided not to. He wouldn't
say he felt calm exactly; maybe disconnected.
He didn't feel particularly hungry, he didn't
feel particularly tired, he didn't feel much at
all. His concrete limbs were only a passing
curiosity to him as he sat in his chair.
Very occasionally, he would get up
to put a record on his record player,
then return to his seat and stare
at the wall. That would be every
couple of months at most. The rest
of the time, he would just sit there.
One day, he noticed in a vague corner
of his mind that the ground was shaking
and dust was filling the room. The ripping
sound of dynamite and the heavy stone just
above his head told him that the apartment
block towering over him had fallen down
and almost come through his ceiling.
Robert just sat there, unconcerned.
Another day, some indeterminate time
later, a group of builders came in
dressed in peculiar futuristic clothing, with
bright yellow hats and reflective vests. They
seemed rather startled to see him, though in
truth, he had little care for seeing them.
What did perturb him was when a
group of people claiming to be
agents from the "Foundation" came
into his room and carried him out.
He didn't like the noise, didn't like the
change. If he wanted to move, he would move,
not that he could, of course. He was now
entirely made of concrete, but that was
beside the point. These people put him in the
back of a van and drove him across half of the
United States. They wheeled him through brightly
lit rooms and into a disgusting modern white box.
They had done the courtesy of bringing his chair
along and found a new record player for him,
with a whole selection of albums lining a shelf
on the wall. He would have appreciated it and
said thank you to them, but he didn't really
care. He wasn't present at all. This was,
of course, due to the fact that he
was made of concrete by this point.
However, once he was sat in his chair
and took in the sight in front of him,
Robert Chetford felt a dull panic rising in
his chest. They'd placed him at a window,
just like he'd placed his dying mother in
front of a window. He tried to clench his jaw,
tried to move his hands, tried to cry out in
fear and pain, but he couldn't. He was paralyzed.
The smell of smoke filled his chest, choking
him, torturing him as the memories of his
burning household raged in his mind. He
tried to scream. He tried to fight. He
tried to do anything other than sit there.
But it was far too late for any of that.
*
"Good afternoon, Mr. Chetford," the
researcher said, busying herself and
putting on another album for him to listen
to. "Is there anything I can do for you,
sir? Anything I can do to
make you more comfortable?"
The concrete man said nothing. The researcher
patted him on the back of his hand.
"Made of concrete indeed. Looks
just like regular skin to me,
Mr. Chetford. I do wonder what's
going on inside that head of yours."
On her way out of the room, she
glanced at his view from the window.
"Beautiful weather outside
today, isn't it? Scorching even."
Now go check out “SCP-011 - Sentient Civil
War Memorial” and “SCP-650 -
Startling Statue” for more!